[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
petit duplexe au sacré cœur et le
complexe du
bonheur vendredi
13 tout le confort à la maison et pour
garder son petit
garçon une
portugaise pas grandchose de diff
des autres femmes de 30
ans sur cette
bute mis à part un petit détail quand
elle se rend à son travail c'est pour
aller faire la
bute comme les filles de son espèce elle
prend ses quartiers de
noblesse au fond des
ses collègues sont en vérité de petites
sœurs de
pas
d'avantage les malheureux au cœur
blessés tous les amoureux
délaissés ceux qui
débutent les paumés de la société
compagnons de la timidité vont trouver
l'amour chez les
comme beaucoup de ses compagnes
elle est venue de sa
campagne chercher
fortune il y a des trésors pleins la
terre mais elle assure qu'elle préfère
ce duitune
elle ne croit pas avir son âme plus
noire que celle des autres
femmes que l'on
culb mais dans ce monde unisexué il y a
autant d'hommes en vérité que de jeunes
femmes qui font la
le s'en va vite et le temps cou
dans ce vieux métier de
l'amour qui l'a fait
vivre mais elle gagne assez d'argent et
dans 10 ans ou dans 20 ans
elle sera
libre fini les dures nuits d'hiver et
les pris dans les courants
d'air que l'on
discute à nous la mer et le soleil mais
ça n'est pas demain la veille ce soir il
faire la
[Musique]